this is a production of Cornell
University
[Applause]
good morning I'm here to talk fast be
chirpy and funny and get a delivers
right into lunch is that about right
keep you awake right in up to lunch so
hi everybody I see some familiar faces
which is weird
so let's get funky any kind of fun I
will introduce myself here these are all
of the things I am and I think there's
might be some lies in there too that I'm
not no-nonsense that's a my not no
nonsense are my no nonsense
I think I'm not no nonsense it's hard to
say I'm a blogger I've written a
gardening blog for 12 years which in
blogging is a really long time I started
working in garden centers in my 20s
after being a manager at Starbucks it
was like totally normal right manager at
Starbucks
quit that frappuccinos came out I was
like screw this I'm out of here I'm
going to go water plants for ten years
and that's what I did so I've been
working in gardening since then I'm a
very serious person
I make no jokes at all and I never lie
I'm a mom a daisy troop leader a
Chicagoan I'm a columnist at Green
profit I'm assuming that's why I'm here
and it's not the baby troop leader part
but you never know
I'm humorless I'm a speaker I have a
tattoo of social pruners on my arm
because I there are the nicest things
I've ever owned it's when I got the
tattoo it was the nicest thing I'd ever
owned was was two pairs of self Oh
pruners I never had any quality tools in
my life until then and I'm very bland
and boring and I have terrible eyesight
does me now you know everything about me
that's all you need to know so garden
centers are my big my big thing and I go
to every garden center I can I could I
could plan vacations around stuffing at
garden centers and I notice a lot of
things and a lot of things that we're
doing right a lot of things that we're
doing wrong my first thing is why why
garden centers are retail but they don't
know one who owns when it runs on it
often runs one like it is retail it's
like those rules don't apply to us
a lot of customers don't really get how
to shop new customers don't really get
how to shop for plants or how to operate
in the garden center and another
Starbucks reference do you remember the
first time you went to Starbucks when
you were like you needed to have a
friend to help you figure it out well
guess what garden centers are like that
for new gardeners and new shoppers they
have no idea where to get your wagon or
where to check out or how things work
because it's not like the grocery store
or Target or growth of the drugstore or
anything it's just totally different
rules and we don't really go we don't
really try to help with new people at
all so I love this idea which is like a
new new gardener start here I don't
think it's like the flashiest display
ever I think I would totally kick this
up a few notches but this is a good
representation of a beginning I also a
big fan of having a having picking a
night of the month or a night of the
week or a day of the week and this is
new customer day you put out the banner
hey every Tuesday new customers welcome
we have extra special staff here to help
new people there extra patient and extra
smart every Tuesday of course it's the
same staff you always have but Stephanie
you guys right now you get some t-shirts
like we are the special Tuesday extra
caring sensitive staff for new people
and of course it's just the same people
so beginners say once or twice a month
or you can advertise it you can use
social media which I know everyone loves
so much and they're praying I don't talk
about what your prayers will go
unanswered you can have beginner
specialists of course the same old
people and you make sure that you post
banners saying beginners are welcome a
beginners welcome banner on a beautiful
established garden center is a huge deal
to someone who always drove I was always
curious but scared poopless to go in
it happens I know it's hard to imagine
infographics are really important
I hate handouts and I'm still doing this
anyways because they're the right thing
to do just because I hate handouts
they're killing trees and there's no
really great way to hand em out other
than those little plastic take one
things there's something that you should
have maybe even at the register you
should also have your own infographics
and offer them online and use them in
social media make sure that you're using
a merchandising to lead the way lead
people all the way through your garden
center from the beginning and so that
they hit everything that you want use
potted plants to move people through so
that they can't get through to other
areas you want to lead them all the way
through make sure that their eye is
going exactly where you want them to and
you're hiding the things you don't want
them the same so this is a great way to
funnel they're funneling people right
towards the door and here's another
great way you not follow a line of
bowling balls right who is not curious
about what's going on at once you want
that wood is going to go on past there
it costs next to nothing to use bowling
balls I know this for sure because I
have them at my house and Mike neighbors
complain about them it costs nothing to
do this and people are always curious
and pizza delivery guys love me my
neighbors don't but the pizza delivery
guys they get me and really who do I
need to impress in life the pizza
delivery guys are my neighbors pizza
delivery guys every time if one pizza
delivery guy had just had twins
Luke and Leia and I was like we're this
we are you are my people Luke and Leia
you are my people
so I don't care what the neighbors I
care about the guy who's a dad of Luke
and Leia that makes him Jarrett's Peter
I don't I didn't spoil anything for you
that movie came out in 1977
okay so while you're leading people
around your store you also want to
inspire them give them ideas how things
can come together and this is how you
add the sales they don't just want to
come in for one plant they come in for
two plants that come in for the pasta to
come in for the soil that buy everything
so you're directing people through your
garden center while you're also selling
them ideas my favorite favorite garden
center trick is to use the ground know
no one ever does that I make arrows
through garden centers I write soil this
way and draw an arrow I've made very
intricate oriental rugs underneath patio
sets out of chalk I also get young
people like six seven eight years old to
help me out with that so it's really
obviously very elaborate and always
stays within the lines chalk paint you
name it use the ground to direct people
you can use stuff to dish ously I know
that we get in that truckload of 300
knockout roses and we just make a pile
of 300 knockout roses right there none
of those knockout roses going to extract
but it just stay in a pile until they
dwindle in September use things more
judiciously so use those 300 knockout
roses to make your entire path going all
the way down yeah it's more work but
they're there you might have will use
them and then use actual visual
merchandizing cues like at the grocery
store where they keep the milk in the
back you just put those pink petunias in
the back right put the the hanging
baskets in the back so people have to go
through and be subjected to all your
awesome products and awesome ideas on
the way back to get those totally boring
things
so in the kiss my after vortex from one
to ten of how boring or cool a display
could be this is like a 1 this is like
as boring as a display could be as
luscious as this point could be it's
just a little bit better than basic this
is not it's cool but it's not that cool
we can do better now we're now we're
talking we got some color we got some
weird stuff in there it's not enough
plants for my liking but it's giving
ideas it's giving people permission
which I think that people desperately
need these days permission to let their
freak flag fly in their backyard
gardening used to be an expression of
creativity and I feel now like it's
becoming more of an expression of God
don't let my neighbors hate me it's like
it's like this bar is set for like beige
beige gardening and we need to bring
back the weird in gardening and that is
why I have two mannequins and twelve
pipe organ pipes in mics and in my
garden I'm doing my part to help all of
you bring gardening back to fun and
funky so what can you do to create a
conversation I feel like many gardening
centers are ruled with the fear of what
if I upset somebody and we left that one
squeaky person who complains that
something's inappropriate or something's
not not right or not it's just not the
what the thing that they want to see and
we let that one person who's going to
complain keep us from impressing a lot
more people if that bus loads of people
who be like that's cool I want I want to
talk about this place I want to
Instagram this place I want to tell my
friends like hey they have this sign of
like a prayer Karen this is what we want
right we we want to create a buzz and a
sensation with very little effort this
is just a little bit of paint and a lot
of cactuses right but it's funny I know
when I go into a garden center that
these are my people and
that I'm going to from seeing a sign
like this I know that I'm going to get
along with the people that work there
get along with the management and that
they probably have cooler stuff than
other garden centers that may not take
this kind of a risk matter no so again
this is this tells me that I'm shopping
someplace cool it makes me feel cool to
be there and and I know that the people
that work there have a sense of humor
and that they that they are going to
have something to talk to me about that
they have something to offer me and I'm
just so into that I want to connect with
the people that work there this I was
surprised this is a garden center I
never would have gone into it's the kind
of it's still in Chicago but it's just
outside of Chicago and it's the kind of
place that I would have driven past I
just figured that they have dreams and
spikes never would go in there I saw
this and I'm like going in I'm going to
go in I'm going to obviously I was wrong
about them they're obviously cool and
funny and I was wrong it doesn't cost
anything right and you don't even have
to really be that original this stuff's
out there who hasn't done that we're so
excited we wet our plants it's still
funny we've all seen it we've all been
scented into our inboxes 37 times in 30
sometime you're like yeah what our plans
huh but guess what it's still funny you
still put that plant out front people
are still going to laugh it's it doesn't
take much people
it doesn't take much we're still with it
I mean it they're having fun it's
something that you know going back in
social media this is something that if I
swap us in a garden center I would
absolutely share this I would absolutely
put it on my Facebook page and send it
out to four thousand people and I would
share the location of this and we would
have everyone would have a little talk
about it and we're not we're just not
having this kind of fun day today
I know aquascape has a peeing dog water
feature have any of you seen that so
it's like 24-hour of dog peeing you can
have it anywhere you want just like but
I like this too I would maybe think that
a storefront like this was a little too
fancy for me because I like a little bit
of a I don't know a challenge but it
would this out front I would absolutely
check it out this would be the number
one thing that would get me into a
garden center I feel I know garden
centers have they make a list of their
top selling plants and they eliminate
the bottom what 15% every year the
bottom 15% are exactly what I want to be
lying I want to be buying those bottom
15% who you don't get rid of the bottom
15% take that bottom 15% put it on an
end cap and have a have a sales person
standing there being like these are
weird plants and this is why they're
weird and this is how you can grow them
and then you have weird plants even
people who don't know a petunia from a
tomato steak
want to have something cool and
different but they just needed to
explain to them so why are we we're
becoming more
so basically we're becoming more like
the big boxes and just selling basic
stuff and getting rid of the cool stuff
oh gosh it makes me good it bothers me I
think we could use this a garden center
super sexy fail we need the sexy and
gardening bring it plants are all about
sex it's not untrue we can have the
geranium super sexy geranium sale let's
do it
color-blocking that's some photo worthy
right it doesn't cost much to make a
display like this and this is I think
it's for a grub in California which is
something that people have photographs
of thousands of time and shared these
photos thousands of times and when
people take a vacation out there
something that they want to see and take
their picture next to can you imagine
having your garden Center as a vacation
destination why not I mean why can't you
imagine that how much do you think it
costs to get an old rusty car dropped in
your garden center and use it as a shelf
or plant I just need the space right and
the rat so realistically you're not
going to copycat this but I will tell
you the story I worked at a gardening
center in downtown Chicago which is a
weird place to be to be selling plants
and look up and there's skyscrapers all
around it was an unusual place to sell
plants to people who never felt didn't
feel grass near their feet in a daily
basis so it wasn't already an unusual
customer base two of my three of my
greatest fights with customers there the
first guy who was really upset that I
told him that Boston Ivy wouldn't grow
on his entertainment system the woman
who didn't understand why I told her she
couldn't have a cut leaf Japanese maple
growing in her dining room but my
favorite is the guy who wanted he had a
Fraser for a fresh cut Fraser Fir for
Christmas he called us in March he said
you you don't understand it's really
doing very well I'm a wealthy man I'd
like you to root this for me
and I made the mistake of saying sir we
can't do that I really should have just
taken his money and giving him a balding
burlap Frasier for what well with me but
it looks a little different well it's
been through it's been through some
things the routing process is very
difficult sir so ask this garden center
for fall when things are slowing down
I took a good 48 inch terra cotta pot
and put a rebar in it and I built those
three cage topiaries out of chicken wire
filled it with moss and soil and
inserted little 4-inch cabbages so it
was it was like 12 feet tall when I was
done and I never got to being done
because it turns out nothing sells four
inch cabbages at 795 in downtown Chicago
like like someone playing with them
basically me touching them and adding
them to this topiary ain't meant that
they sold faster than any cabbages have
ever sold for 795 so I never got to
finish it because it just drew so much
attention the act of putting a display
together in front of other people if
theater people like it there's a story
cute hey I bought this cabbage today it
was 795 but this lady was putting it at
the top of this it was going to be the
last one so I bought it there's the kind
of person that appeals to you sadly
there's all kinds of things you can use
to make things cool and give them a
story hey I bought this horse tail rush
today it was in an old rusty Dasom hey I
bought some succulents they were under a
decrepid piano it was kind of cool I
took a picture it's not just a plant
it's an experience buying something out
of a old stove this is at a garden
center outside of Chicago you can't
really tell it's lit up at night and
they're old shovels and rakes that had
been coated with glue and glitter toss
them nothing these things end up as sign
holders to hang them from the greenhouse
ceiling and they hang signs off of it
they lay them on either side
a walk way to guide people from walking
they've used these littered tools for
everything and they just have a ton of
them so it didn't cost anything that to
do it and it's just a really fun thing
for them something for everybody
glitters fun for everybody I know that
you don't want me to talk about social
media but I have to so here are some
things that I know about social media
that come with fun and funky is that
even when you're posting things and
there's no interactions it seems like no
one's looking that's the new thing that
the kids are doing now is that they
don't even give you a like it's not even
if they're if it's so cool they won't
even push like so you just have to just
have to keep going even though you're
getting absolutely no validation for it
at all and just because you're the boss
doesn't mean you need to be doing social
media you need to find someone who
enjoys doing it and let them do it and
it doesn't have to be one person it can
be a team of people and I can't push
Instagram at you hard enough in other
industries they are using our tools for
visual merchandising way better than we
are let's let that soak in for a second
we're selling high-end
shoes here using our wheelbarrows what's
up with that so this is a little fancy
jewelry store using our stuff would we
ever think of using that no to us these
are tools you don't use these interest
it would be bizarre but it isn't we
should be doing this it's pointing down
basically they're like arrows pointing
down at the things they want you to buy
make sure that we're merchandising for
all generations and all price points I'm
a big believer in terrariums because
they can be made for nothing we can use
things we find on the ground at work to
make a terrarium right little droppings
of succulents little pieces of this and
little pieces of that they cost nothing
I make them out of old spaghetti jars
Ball jars things I find as a thrift
store we could be making and selling
terrariums for next to nothing and that
can be a really great draw and it's a
really great draw in the winter
here they're using the health strip
gardening book to to market both the
book and the plant so this is a very
specific kind of gardening for city
dwellers people who have that that
health strip you know that is right the
area between the road and the sidewalk
so it's also for me it's the pizza oven
because all that hard scape and gets so
hot that everything just wants to to
kind of burn up and die there so so
they're selling the books they're cross
promoting with the plants they have
taken the plants from the book and
they're they're doing that I believe
that the Millennials have burned through
the air plants and they won't be doing
that again
and now they're burning through
succulents and cactuses are it there
they're going to be here for for kind of
a while and so gear up for that little
thrift store tea cups with succulents in
it this costs so little to do and this
is so much basically if you have someone
who comes in and they want succulents
there's a good chance that this is what
they wanted to make with it but if
you're already offering it they'll take
that shortcut but you have to have it
for them to buy it here's a happy spring
thing for kids to appreciate so this was
pretty for all of us but this is the
kind of place that if I took my daughter
who's six to a garden center and she
would then recall that experience would
be like hey mom let's go to the place
with the rain boots outside does this
make sense
it's something that even kids would find
whimsical and interesting not just
adults and we all have the piles of
stinky boots so it's not like that would
cost anything either you've been wanting
to throw those boots away for at least
four years so just hang them from the
fence and plant them up
it's I like rough rust and I we go way
back so here's something interesting
adding a little bit of whimsy how much
would it cost to French braid some
Miscanthus nothing and why didn't you
guys already think of this I mean really
where's your head at we couldn't be
French braiding Miscanthus I have in
before I never thought of this but I did
buy cheap clips that looks like hair
bows and I put them in Miscanthus to try
to get my daughter to play with grasses
I don't know why I wanted to do that she
makes it her time machine she steps into
the Miscanthus and she says coming out
in a different time and she we can all
be adding a little bit of whimsy and
this really is going to hook in these
generators are called Generation V the
youngest kids I think we may have it was
the baby boomers and we've gone right to
Millennials we never really got
Generation X our chance hmm
and and really digging into Generation Z
is going to be where we need to be we
need to take the lesson of completely
forgetting about X and already start
focusing on Z and welcoming them into
garden centers creating a little bit of
whimsy play spaces V is young right
they're 20 and younger so we need to to
really open up fun spots for them one
way you can do that for free is to let
the kids paint a rock while their mom or
dad shop met Rock lives in the garden
center you think that kids going to want
to come back and visit that rock you
think you're going to hear hey mom I
want to go to the place and visit my
rock oh yes that kid is going to want to
visit their rocks so you're going to
have our return visit right then there
you can let kids paint on a fence and
like in Chicago we have a lot of
restaurants that encourage graffiti it
could be that kind of thing the graffiti
becomes once it gets layered up to you
know a couple summers of it it becomes
with some kind of weird art so you can
let kids paint their own faces on on
fence posts while the parent shop
you can have a little obstacle course
from the crawl-through kids garden you
can show parents exactly how to do a
kid's garden how to make it fun how to
get kids involved in gardening and this
way you can sell a lot of those little
plastic shovel with butterflies on it
too I think that they might be the
easiest to reach and they're right now
they're the most loyal my daughter has
such a fun time when we go to Ikea she
asks to go to Ikea all the time we could
be doing that at garden centers garden
centers are a heck of a lot more fun
than IKEA I mean really almost anything
is except the Swedish meatballs are
really on point we can be creating that
kind of fun very easily this is just a
pile of dirt for kids to play with how
hard was it for us I mean really your
kids have some dirt to play with okay I
want to come back to the rest of my life
in autumn we have a hard time
merchandising those pumpkins so why not
make a little labyrinth for kids to walk
through it would cost nothing to do this
this is just layout I love doing this
with mown grass too if you have a lot of
a few of a field let the field grow for
two weeks and then mow a labyrinth in
the grass and that's a great way to keep
kids busy and excited and create an
experience that they're going to want to
recapture fairy gardens are so not my
favorite thing they're not I wish that
they would go away but they're not going
to this is well done this is really
great things that need to be
reupholstered are next to free on
Craigslist or in junkyards or first
doors and this could be very easily
replicated this is really not a big deal
it looks like a big deal really isn't a
big deal how to best be part of your
community make sure that you're offering
classes this is a real thing this is
what is called silks it's a big deal I
don't know if every greenhouse can
support you know a group of 15 people
doing this um no but you could be doing
yoga easily especially in the winter if
you're already heating those greenhouses
anyways
you could actually have people coming in
and having our yoga and then maybe they
buy a plan on their way out maybe they
don't painting classes are awful but
they come with is lots of wine and a
liquored up customer is always a
customer with an open purse I strongly
recommend that plants and wine they go
together these starting classes have
been a really big deal in early spring
the important thing is that as we all
know people want to start their seeds in
January when it's way too early to start
their seeds so you need to be setting
some pretty strong messages in January
that yes we have a seed starting class
in March when you're supposed to be
doing it pruning classes have been a big
deal fancy cocktails like growing lemon
verbena for cocktails and here's what
you do would have been very popular
canning and preserving is a huge deal
and if you sell canning and preserving
stuff it's just perfect actual gardening
classes I don't know kind of pass a
knitting you could just sit around in it
have a knitting circle come and sit in
your greenhouse or a garden center and
book clubs book clubs also come with
wine that's the deal make sure if you
can do events it's a lot of money in
events people keep getting married
what's up with that
and there's money in it it's just it's
just people open their pockets and they
just start throwing around when when
you're getting married weddings parties
charity fundraisers meeting space
especially for garden clubs I know a lot
of garden clubs are always looking for
space moms night out is this thing where
they each each mom and the group has to
take a different night in the month and
they they try to up the other mom and it
ends up where they're renting out the
entire garden centers and doing planted
container parties and this is the real
thing and you don't charge them much
other than enough to keep the place open
and then give them a little discount on
the plants in the past and you have
guaranteed
or 20 sales that night it's not such a
bad way to stay open straw bales are
great for everything this is a wedding
at a garden center can you identify the
actual garden center in there the main
point is that you and your staff are
having fun the customers will feel it
and it's it's important that it doesn't
become drudgery especially when it's 98
degrees out and you just got to get that
stuff watered eight times and every time
you pick up the hose someone's like
excuse me where's the geraniums and
spikes you still have to make it fun and
I recommend that these would help if you
could get one of these for everybody on
your staff
it's the most truthy gardening shirt
ever yeah so that's it
Cuban question you just like where's
lunch right questions were discussing
height or you if you want to yell at me
and tell me I'm wrong I can't tell you
about it I may have told you about it
under the duress of some sangria sir but
I am not allowed to talk about my new
book I can talk about the old book but
everyone calling on campus I can tell
you what's old book the old book is it
was it's a at new home Wow there it is
right there
yes exactly what it looks like it's
aimed towards new homeowners who they
buy a house and they have this existing
landscaping that just isn't their taste
and it's a graphic guide so it's the the
illustrations are very trippy and a
little bit psychedelic and odd there's
not a lot of text in it at the end of
each page you choose you choose your own
adventure so you don't have to read the
whole book you can just read the parts
you want it is a very weird book with at
least five references the Beastie Boys
six references the spinal tap and two
references to Star Wars just like this
this presentation so yeah and I'm
working on a second book but I'm not
allowed to talk about it unless I've had
sangria and if you don't have sangria
with you you have some
I might abandon it yes sir yes why why
Instagram yeah and you know what instead
of instead of telling you I maybe I can
show you a couple garden centers that
are killing Instagram would you like to
see that all right let's take a look
there are garden centers on Instagram
they are followed by every gardener in
America not just in their area so if
they're killing it if they're really
doing a great job let me see here
Instagram so let's see here let me find
one right away
those just hope there's nothing
inappropriate in here okay here's here's
one natural plus in Iowa so like even
just something like this is just Genie
genius and they've got 12 likes on it
which is kind of a lot in the world of
this sort of thing and kind of see some
of the things they're doing let's see if
we can find a little someone who's doing
a little bit racier things here you know
what I'll do I will do a search here
I don't know so Instagram is you just
photos and you post something like a
sale here like look at this great thing
it gives you every all the information
you need there in the photo and then on
the bottom right here it gives you all
their information that you need to know
they didn't use any hashtags if your
hashtags phobic I know some people just
are like hashtags are stupid they're not
stupid they have a really great function
which is they create a live link to
anything else in that area so if you
don't at least use your towns name
that's I mean that's the least thing you
could do if I take pictures at a garden
center I use the hashtag independent
garden centers and garden centers which
means you click on that you can see
pictures of independent garden centers
all around the world that's kind of cool
right if someone's interested in
independent garden centers and they can
check them all out let's see what else
they're doing here pictures of can't lie
every third or fourth photo should not
be pictures of product pictures of how
many people come Wow you see this
picture scroll across the screen why
wouldn't you want hey a lot of people
show up that I miss out on that I want
to go to that next year right you feel
that way when you see this this must be
a pretty good thing if there's that many
people there flash-sale cute stuff so
you this is something that you should be
doing every day and if it isn't if you
have no idea where to start start at a
today is a picture of Ansonia tomorrow
the picture of buddleja and you you
write a little something about what you
know about that plant how much it is and
where you're at make sure I know a lot
of garden centers to on their front page
don't even have their address or town
address and town is important the
address in town is important but it's
not rocket science it doesn't have to be
the most creative thing in the world it
just has to be the truth of what your
garden center is about give a little
flavor of where you are and you need to
try to speak out other people in your
area and follow them and they'll usually
follow you back anything else
questions the comments are my favorite
part you guys so listening yes sir I
don't I don't I I'm not sure
because Terry Gardens is going to stick
around for a long time and it's just so
cheap and plasticky and I would like it
I would like fairy gardening to be a
little bit more authentic or how can you
have an authentic fairy garden I would
be then insinuating that fairies are not
real I was like I was like stormtrooper
gardening to come in I would like a you
know hole to build a Death Star out of
begonias and blow it up I mean I would
just like it to be more fun and less
cheesy so I don't I it's nothing I have
a problem with the idea of fairy
gardening I have the real problem with
the way it played out was there another
question because I love questions so
much yes that's my job
right and my my first garden center boss
is my best friend's mom okay so I she's
taught me everything I know just her
daughter my best friend garden she does
her pot she knows what she likes she has
a lot of knowledge from being exposed to
it but she is not interested so I have a
daughter who knows six years old the
name of all the plants and stuff so
let's see a ball
Thanks we'll see yes
yeah well I mean it depends on if you
I wasn't saying depends but if you like
your if you like your landscaping you
don't I was like cut down the burning
bush
kill it with fire and also douse that
gasoline on it all those three things
it's bigger than that I would say I mean
I'm a huge core aeration believer I mess
usually most people I talk to they worry
too much about their lawn they want a
perfect lawn and I slapped them twice
once this way and once that way and tell
them the snap out of it and I give them
a long rant about about lawns and who
are they really supporting and after my
rant is over I can then like what you
can cor aerate it's a pretty good way to
get moist down to the roots and you also
like I'm a big big fan of that I would
talk to someone about making sure red
mulch doesn't ever taint your property
and I would I would talk about growing
food because it's such a rewarding thing
it's like when you start harvesting it's
like winning this personal lottery in
your mind every day right if we can get
young gardeners to feel that feeling
well we'll really we can trick them we
can trick them the rest of the way
before you know it they'll be buying
paper bark birches yes what isn't in my
front yard I'm tearing out the turf in
my front yard and putting in a a big
drifts of perennials I have a
mid-century modern ranch so I'm trying
to keep it kind of modern looking I try
to keep it a little bit more business in
front and party in the back so I have a
at my front door which is kind of
recessed I have this summer theme was a
tribute to the Polynesian Resort at Walt
Disney World so it's all tropical plants
and there's a mannequin there handing
out leis and she's in a tropical dress
and that's totally normal right
and I have a chair with a pillow with
the Dole Whip on it if you've ever had a
Dole Whip you'll be like I will
that pillow right have you had a dual
whip no okay all right so the whole
front door is tropical right now and
I've got dahlias and tomatoes and coming
out of swaths of bronze fennel and
perilla it's very weird but I get a lot
of compliments on it it's taken me five
years to do a chunk because I have a six
year old I'm hoping to increase my speed
now that she's six I have a lot more to
do the backyard is a lot weirder there's
a tattoo Shack a mud laboratory of the
pipe organ pipe several old bicycles and
a lot of bowling balls a lot of plants
you know we've got to balance it off it
can't just be planned that's too easy
too easy anything else yes then it's
such a strong statement
all right I'm going to tell you what I'm
going to tell you why you're wrong and
and I backed me up ladies bones eyes for
dude you say so Voldemort
[Music]
I would say that bonsai takes so much
care and control and I have I personally
have no time for that and I would say
that a lot of women would feel that way
too is it controlling yes yes
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu